Learn to use R to build an interactive data
driven application with the R shiny package.
Dr. Chanin Nantasenamat, also known as the
Data Professor, teaches this course. Besides
teaching on his YouTube channel, he is also a
university professor. You probably know that the
our programming language can help you to perform
statistical analysis. But did you know that you
could use our to build an interactive data driven
web application. In this course on Free Code Camp,
you will be learning about how you could use
the our shiny package to build an interactive
and data driven web application that will
range from a simple application that allows
you to print user inputs, web applications that
will allow you to display data visualization,
as well as web application that will allow you
to make predictions from machine learning models.
Finally, you'll be learning how to deploy
the web applications that you have created
to the cloud by means of the Heroku platform.
All codes that are used in this tutorial will
be provided in the video description.
And without further ado, let's dive in.
Before we begin, let's cover the basics of what
is a shiny package. so shiny is an art package
that allows you to build an interactive web
application, there are several extension packages
that will allow you to extend the function of
shiny, including shiny themes, shiny dashboard,
shiny j, s and several others. And
once you develop your web app in shiny,
then you want to deploy it. So you have two
options, you want to deploy it on your own server,
for example, using a service like Digital Ocean
or to a shiny apps.io. There are lots of example
codes that can get you started. And
this is available in the shiny gallery.
So the links are in the slides. Okay, so
what we will learn today, first of all,
we will learn about the structure of a shiny
web application. And then we're going to have
a look at some of the examples of the shiny web
application. And finally, we will show you step
by step how you can build your interactive web
application. So let's have a look at the structure
of a shiny web application. So essentially, a
shiny web app comprises of three components.
So the first component is the user interface,
which is housed within a file called UI dot r.
And the second is the server function, which
will perform the processing of the data,
which is housed in the file called server dot r.
And then the shiny app function will fuse the UI
and server components together. So the UI is the
front end that accepts the user input values,
the server is the back end that processes these
input values to finally produce output results
that are displayed on the website. Okay, so
you see that input data will flow into the user
interface, which is the website that you see. And
then you will enter data into the text box, and
then the data will be submitted to the server, the
server processes the information, and then it will
produce the result. And the result is displayed on
the websites. Okay, and then the user will see the
results. Okay, so let's have a look at some of the
shiny web applications. So let's go to this link.
Okay, so this is the gallery available from
SHINee. And you can see that there are a lot
of examples. So there are the integration of
maps, right insights, shiny application, and
also interactive scatter plots. You can also embed
Google charts as well, you could perform k means
clustering, you could create some bar charts using
available data set from the data set package.
And then you could also create a word cloud, okay,
and there are several others. And then there are
witches like buttons, tables, slider, input,
slider, K, downloading files, uploading files,
subsetting, data set and all that. Okay, so
there are several examples on how you can
develop custom shiny web apps. So why
don't we click on one, the first one, okay,
so this map is interactive. If we click on it,
we can zoom in. Right, so you click on the color,
and then it will update the map based on
your input are also Data Explorer. So it's an
interactive table. You can also sort the data as
well, okay. Or how about a word cloud generator.
Can you could play around with the
input parameters, minimum frequency
of each word. For example, if it's 25,
it means that the current word like love
has to Be present at least 25 times. So 26
times in order for it to be counted here,
how many words are we limiting to be displayed
here? Okay, and these accept input from the
books of our choice A Midsummer's night dream,
The Merchant of Venice or Romeo and Juliet,
we have to click on the Change button. k.
k means clustering, using the iris dataset,
right. Okay. Okay, and then the next one is to
have a look at some of the web applications coming
out of my own research lab. So let's have a look.
Let's go to code stop bio slash osfp. So as I'm
a bioinformatics researcher, and data scientist,
so what we do in our lab is we try to apply
machine learning in order to make sense of
biological data and chemical data as well.
And so the objective of this web server is
to take as input the protein sequence, and then
we will predict whether the protein sequence is an
oligomer or a monomer. Okay, so let's click on the
Insert example data, and then the input will be a
fast a format of the protein sequence. So the
first line which contains the greater than symbol,
followed by the name of the protein is given here.
So we see that the first protein is a monomer.
And the second protein is a tetra mer. And let's
click on the submit button to make the prediction.
Okay, and so we see that the prediction is
correct on both occasion, because the first
one is a monomer. And it predicts it to be
a monomer. And the second one is a tetramer.
And it predicts it to be an ollie Gomer. Okay,
so this is the interface of the prediction web
server. And if we click on the other buttons, it
will look like any other ordinary website. Okay,
so these are description on how to use the web
server. And they are written in markdown case.
So this shiny app can also embed markdown inside
as well. Okay, so we also provide the data set for
download as well. And we host it on the GitHub.
And if you're interested in reading this paper,
you can click on the link. Okay, so this is
the paper that we published back in 2016,
in the Journal of Chem informatics.
Okay, so let's go back to the slide.
And let's get started. We're creating
our own web app using SHINee. So what
you want to do now is fire up your our
studio or our studio cloud K. And so
the code that will be used today is available
on the data Professor GitHub. So if you go to
github.com, slash data professor,
okay, and then you click on code,
and then find SHINee slash 001 first app. And then
you want to click on App dot r. And then you want
to right click on the raw button right here.
And then you want to click on the safelink s,
and then select a suitable position
where you want to save the file.
And because I already have it, I will just
click on Cancel, but if you don't have it yet,
click on the Save button. Okay, so let's open up
the app dot our file right inside the our studio.
Okay, so before we begin a credit to Winston
Chang for developing this template by which
we greatly modified and simplified to make this
app dot our file. So if you want to check out the
full version, go ahead here, links are provided
here. Okay, so in this simplification, we're going
to start with the baby steps. So this web app is
an interactive web application whereby it will
accept input values in the form of text, primarily
the given name and surname. So let's have a look.
Okay, so the app will accept input which has the
given name and the surname Okay, so let's go ahead
and type the given name john and insert name is
still okay, and so the name john doe will appear
in the output here and the name of the app this
my first app, you can also modify this to your
own liking, okay, and in this example, we have
three navigation bar so we intentionally left
it blank here, according to the original template
by Winston Chang. Okay, so the code that we have
is located on the nav bar dot one so a point in
notice that you can also create several web apps
inside different navigation bar. Let's say that
you want to modify the name like let's say given
name is Jennifer. So then you'll see that the
name is automatically updated. So notice that
there is no Submit button and whenever you type in
an updated name, it will automatically update the
results. So in our they implement reactive, let's
have a look shiny, reactive, reactive expressions,
reactivity and overview, okay, so it's based
on the principles of reactive programming,
which is used by the shiny package.
So we're not going to go into detail.
But if you're interested, I can also
provide the links in the file as well.
concepts about reactive
programming used by SHINee.
Okay, so I'm going to provide
the link for you, here.
Okay, so a moment ago, we have taken a look
at how the web application will look like,
which is the end outcome of this code. So let's
look under the hood, what does the code looks
like? Okay, so in the slides, I've shown to
you that it comprises of three components.
So let's have a look. So the first
component is the UI is right here.
So it's on line 19, until lines 43k, lines
19 until lines 43. This is the UI or the user
interface, and then a lines 47 until 52 is the
server component. So you're going to notice that
we're not doing anything much here. We're just
displaying the results. And so the code is very
concise. And the third component is the shiny app
function. So this thing will piece together the UI
and the server. So it's essentially just saying
that, okay, this part here is the UI. This part
here is the server and fused in both to create
a shiny app object. Okay, so that's all there
is to it at the conceptual level. So let's have a
look at the components inside the UI object. Okay,
so here is using inside the fluid page tag, it's
using the theme argument, and it's telling that we
want to use the C raelian. theme. Okay. And the
C rolling theme is the blue theme that you've
seen a moment ago. Let's say I want to change
it to United. And I can click on the reload,
or I need to save it first. And then I'll click
on the reload, and then it changes to the United
Can I want to change to say Yeti, save it,
and then it becomes the Yeti theme. So maybe
you're wondering, what's the available options for
you. So if you search for shiny themes in Google
key, the first results and just click on it.
So here, this is how a civilian looks like,
if you like that you could type in zulian there's
Cosmo Cyborg darkly, paper, lumen journal, flatly
readable? sandstone, simplex, slate, Space Lab,
superhero, united and Yeti. Let's try superhero.
Okay, so it's john doe. Okay. There you go.
By just default back to civilian. So let's
envisage the code as modular components. So you're
going to see that inside the UI, you're going to
have a fluid page, you can within this fluid page,
you're going to define the theme. And inside
the fluid page, aside from the theme, you're
going to have a navigation bar page, right? So
the navigation bar page is right here. It's this
bar. And so the name of the app is my first app.
So this is the name of the navigation bar page.
Inside the nav bar page, there is the tab panel.
Okay, so tab panel comprises of nav bar, one nav,
bar, two nav, bar, three can inside and out
more. One, you have the sidebar panel right here
to the left, right, you have here sidebar panel,
and your sidebar panel contains tag h3, h3 is the
heading third level heading input. And then text
input is the given name. And the text input is the
type of input. So if you change this to something
else, it will look differently here. And there
are a lot of widgets, okay, so you can find what
you want. You can shop for what widget you like,
and then just replace it right here in the code.
Okay, so the given name is right here, displayed
here. And then this thing here is the default
value. So let's say that I could type in john doe,
and let's save it and reload the app. So you see
that john doe will automatically by default appear
in the text box, okay, but I can also leave it
blank as well. Right. So this is the contents
of the sidebar panel. So the sidebar panel will
accept The input right and then the main panel is
right here where we see header one output one john
doe, which is the result. So in main panel one,
right Heather one is inside the h1. So h1 is the
tag, which is the biggest tag available. And h4 is
a smaller tag, right? So we have in order of from
big to small, we have h1 and h2 h3, h4, right. So
for the input here, we use h3, if we change it to
h1, it will be bigger. It'll be the same size as
the header one here, but it's too big. So I'm
going to change it to just h3 we couldn't even
make this a stream as well. Right, so you've got a
little bit bigger for the output one here. Right,
so you can play around with changing the options
here. Okay, and so verbatim text output is simply
a text box that will return the output value. So
it's just a simple text box, and then the nav bar
to nav bar three, as we have previously mentioned,
it is intentionally left blank. Okay, so there's,
that's all there is to the UI. But the confusing
part is how does UI and server interact? How
do they send information back and forth? Right?
How does UI send the input value to the server?
And how does the server accept the input value?
Okay, let's have a look right here. So notice that
the text box has this thing called text one. txt
one right in the given name, okay. And a surname
is txt two, okay. Now, this stat make a note of
that, how about I put it in the comments t x T one
and T x T two, okay, and make a note of this to
t x t out. txt or UT okay. So, these two will be
sent to, to the server TFT to will also be sent to
the server t x t out is generated from the server.
Okay, so let's go back to the slides.
Okay, why don't I create a new slide.
So let's duplicate this slide. So let's
call this the first web app. And we're
going to modify this to reflect the contents
of this web app. So the input data is txt one.
And txt to write and the output is txt
out, right. So it will send txt one and 62
to the server. And so actually, the server sends
write txt out and the TTL will be displayed.
displays. txt out. So here txt one
and txt two will be sent to the server
txt one and txt two here is input dollar sign
txt one and input dollar sign txt to Okay,
and so the question is, how does it send it as a
txt out, it's right here output dollar sign txt
out, and it's going to use this function called
render text. Okay, so there's several render
function like render table render text, right that
you can modify. So you can also find out from the
SHINee documentation, okay, so this output txt
out, what is essentially does is it will use the
paste function to combine TF T one and T two and
separated by a MP space. And then it will produce
the result as the concatenated text of TF T one
and T two inside the txt out variable. And then
this variable will be called from within the
verbatim text output, and then it will display
the text inside the text box. That's all there is
to this shiny web application, it will seem a bit
confusing, but if you get the concepts straight,
it will be very simple. And you could create
any web application to your own imagination,
you can make this web application data driven,
you could ask input, you could upload a file of
the input data and then the input data will be
sent to the server right and then in the server,
you could create a machine learning model and
then once the machine learning model is built, it
would then relate a results back into the UI and
then the UI will display the predicted results.
Okay, so this will be very powerful as a model
deployment approach for your machine learning
model can there's several tips and tricks which
we use in our research lab, and we can share this
in a future video. And so if you're finding value
out of this video, please smash the like button.
Okay, so let me recap this process. In summary,
this app Our file will contain three components
the UI component, which is the user interface,
it will accept input, which is the txt one and
txt two, which corresponds to the given name and
the surname. And when you input the given name
and surname, it will be sent to the server. And
then the paste function will combine tasty one and
txt two and put it inside a txt out variable. And
then this TFT out variable is embedded inside the
verbatim text output, which is a text box on the
UI. And as a result, you will see the input values
that you typed in displayed in the text box.
Okay, so this first web app, which is essentially
starting from the basics, so nothing fancy here,
just a simple web app where you can type in
the name, the first name, last name, and then
it will display the result. Okay, so in future
videos of this series, called the web app in our
we're going to have several other videos. And if
you have ideas on what application you would like
us to develop, let us know. So please comment
down below, and I'll see you in the next one.
Okay, so this video represents the second episode
of the web apps in our series. In the first video,
we covered how you can develop your very first
shiny web app, and the web app allows you to
enter the first name and last name, and the
web app will display the output for a sample.
If you enter the first name as john and the
last name as Doe, then the output panel will
then output john doe. So in this video, we're
going to show you how you can develop your second
web app in R. And so the web app today is really
quite simple. The web app will display a histogram
of the air quality data set, particularly the
ozone levels, and the user will be able to
adjust the bin size, and then the histogram will
adjust accordingly. Okay, so let's get started.
So what you want to do now is go to the data
Professor GitHub, so click on the code folder,
and then click on the shiny folder, and then
click on the 002 histogram. And then what you
want to do now is click on the app dot r, and then
right click on the raw link, and then save link
as and then save it to a desired destination.
So since I have already downloaded the file,
so let's open up the app dot our file. So why
don't we go ahead and run the application.
So as you can see, the web app has the title
as the ozone level and the side panel shown on
the left as the number of bins as a slider input
value. So you can adjust this by sliding to the
left or right and then the resulting histogram
will be updated automatically in real time.
So let's say that we adjusted to seven bins,
and you will see that in the histogram,
there will be a total of seven bars. If
you adjusted to 12, then the number of bins
or the number of bars will then be adjusted to
12. So what is the bin and then in a histogram
is essentially the number of bars and each bar
represents a range in the value for a sample
from the range of zero to five or zero to 10.
And so if you adjust it to one bar, then you
will see only one bar here. And if you adjust to
two bins, you will see two bars, right and etc.
And for a maximum of 50 bars. Okay, so let's go
back to the code. So in this app dot our file, you
will see that on line number nine, it essentially
loads the shiny library and line number 10 will
load the air quality data set into the memory.
And I have already pin the UI in red here.
And the server in red, and the shiny app
function in red. So as in the previous
video, I have already mentioned that the shiny app
has essentially three major components consisting
of the UI component, which is the user interface
and the server component that will accept the
input value from the UI, and it will do some
processing as shown here. And finally it will
generate the output and the output will then be
sent back to the UI for display in the main panel.
Okay, so let's recap that again. So this UI
is the user interface and it will allow you
to specify the name of the title panel here which
is specified as also level. So let's have a look.
So ozone level is specified by the title
panel. So you can modify this name if you like.
Okay, so let's say you want to call it just ozone,
and then you have to save it and then re Load the
app can and the app will then be called ozone.
Okay. Okay, so this is the title panel here.
And the next block of code here will be the
sidebar layout. And the sidebar layout will allow
you to specify the sidebar panel and inside the
sidebar panel will then be a slider input. And the
slider input is essentially the number of bins,
right number of bins in the UI, and it will have
an input ID of bins, which the server component
will recognize. Okay, I'm going to show you in
just a moment. And so the minimum value here is
one and the maximum value of the band is 50. And
the default value is 30. So you see here that the
minimum is one, the maximum is 50. And the default
value is 30. So you can adjust the maximum to say
40. And the fall, you can test it with 20. And
then we will save it and reload the app can and
you're going to see that the web app automatically
updates to 140. And with a default of 20. Okay,
and you when you slide it, it'll update as before.
So here you can see that the step size
is one because when you slide the button,
it will incrementally increase by one. Let's say
that you want to modify the step size to another
number. Can you do that? Yes, you can. So you
want to specify step to be equal to let's say,
two. And the minimum you want, adjust it to
zero, save it and reload the app. And here
now the step size becomes 2k. So 18 and then you
move it it becomes 20 you move it it becomes 22k.
So you notice that I've also modified the
minimum to be zero because if it's one then
a step size will be 13579. But if you make
it into a even number, then the step size
will be also even number Okay, so let's have
a look if the step size is one, it will be 135
right it will be 135. So I cannot select
20. Okay, so it has to be only odd numbers.
So if you want it to be even number then
you want to put the minimum to become zero.
Okay. So here now, you can even
make the step size to be five.
Right? 05 1015 2025 30, right. Okay, so notice
that the slider input has an input ID of bins,
and let's go into the server component. And let's
find bins where spins, spins, it's right here
and bins is right here. Okay, so the server
component will have two bins, the input bins, and
it will be the value of the argument and breaks,
okay, so it will allow you to specify the number
of bins in the histogram and x will be the
air quality data set. And then we use the
dollar sign to specify the column called ozone.
Because in air quality data set, let me stop
the shiny app. First, let's have a look air
quality dollar sign. And then notice that you
have ozone you have solar you have when you have
temperature month. They Okay, so we specify ozone.
And we'll also notice that also on has some
missing data. Right, it has some missing data
here showing us and a the what we're going to
do with the missing data is to omit it from the
data set using the NA dot omit function and
then save it back into the x variable. Okay,
and then the bins variable will then
determine what is the minimum value of the bin
and what is the maximum value of the bin.
Okay, so moving on to the next function
is the histogram function where x is the input
data, which is the air quality or sown column
and the breaks will be equal to the number of
bins that we specify here can so the color will
be discolor, which is bluish color, and the border
will be black. So this is the blue color mentioned
in here and the border is black. So we see a
black line and the x label is also on level.
So the x label is right here. And then the main is
histogram of ozone level. So main is right here,
right? So you can just label or also the main
text as well. So in this output dollar sign
dist plot, we will use the render plot and then
this will generate an output called output dist
plot. And then we're going to know this. If we
screw up to the main panel of the UI component,
the plot output function We'll have an output ID
equals to this plot. Okay, so the name, this plot
here and this point here are the same object.
So the server will generate this output object
called this plot and sends it to the UI component
for display on the main panel. So the main panel
is located right here. Okay, so finally, the shiny
app function will fuse together the UI component
and the server component. So you're going to see
that the code communicates between the UI and the
server, right, so the UI will accept the input,
which is the number of pins and it will send a
number of pins to the server component, and the
server component will generate the histogram plot.
And the histogram plot will be contained
within this output this plot and it will
be sent to the plot output function in the
main panel of the UI. And so you will see
the resulting histogram being generated. And if
you adjust the value of the input bin number,
then the plot will also update automatically
using the reactive function of SHINee. Okay,
so you can customize the color
if you like, let's make it
003366. Okay, so it's dark blue? Or what if we
just call it blue? Or how about let's use red.
Okay, so the plot will
become red, if we use green.
So the histogram will also be green. So here,
you can customize the color to your own liking
and experiment. And don't forget to upload this
to your GitHub so that you can start building your
portfolio for data science projects, and then
you're going to have several repository in your
GitHub in no time. Congratulations, you have
built your second shiny web application in our
Okay, so this is the third episode of the web apps
in our series. So today, we're going to build a
play golf web application. So probably you're
wondering what is a play golf application. So
the play golf web application that we're going
to build today is going to be based on the
weather data set provided by the weeka data mining
software. So let's have a look here. So the data
set is a relatively small data set where it has a
total of five variables. So four variables are the
outlook temperature, humidity, and when and the
class label would be to play or not play golf,
which is a function of the weather and the
condition, right, like whether it is sunny
weather, the temperature is high, whether the
humidity is high, or low or medium, and whether
there is win or not true or false. And then the
final decision is to either play or not play golf.
Okay. So before we dive into the code, let's have
a look at how this the web application looks like.
Okay, so the web app looks like this. It's a very
simple application. So the name of the web app is
play golf. And so here there is the input
parameters comprising of the four variables that
I have mentioned. The first one is the outlook.
And so the user can select one of three outlook,
whether it is sunny, whether there is overcast of
cloud, and also whether there is rain or not. And
the second variable is to temperature. And so this
is a slider input, so the user can slide the input
value, and then the humidity is also a slider
input. And then windy is either a yes or a no,
which is a drop down menu. And then when you're
ready to make a prediction, you just click on the
submit button. Okay, and here you see a prediction
is being made. And the prediction says yes,
and then we also see the underlying probability
in that the know has a 27% probability. And the
yes has a 73% probability. And so you could
play around with this, right? If, for example,
if it is sunny, and the humidity is very high, and
the temperature is very high, and there is when
should you play golf? No, right? I mean, really,
if the temperature is high, it's very humid, and
it's very windy and it's sunny, right? Probably
not. Right. Okay. What if What if the humidity is
low temperature is quite cool, and it's sunny,
and it's not so windy. Would you play golf,
right? Yes. Right. So there's an 87 probability
for Yes, and a 13% probability for No. Okay, so
this is the web app we're going to build today. So
let's go ahead and stop the web app for a moment.
Okay, so what you want to do now is Go to the
data Professor GitHub. And then you want to
click on the code directory, and followed by
clicking on the shiny directory. And finally
clicking on the 003, play golf directory.
And then click on the app dot our file. Okay,
so what you want to do is right click on the
raw link, and then save to file. So I'm going
to save it into the weather folder, save it,
okay, it's right here, click on it,
make sure that the app works. Okay,
it works. prediction has been made. Okay, cool. So
let's just clear up this by pressing on the ctrl
and L button. Okay, so let's have a look under the
hood, what does the app dot our file looks like?
So the first couple of lines, which is import
libraries used by this app dot our file. So
this comprises of the shiny package, shiny themes
package, the data dot table library, the our curl
library and the random forest library. Okay,
so next line of code would be to create a data
object called weather by reading the CSV, which
is downloaded from the data Professor GitHub
in the data folder. And the file is called
weather dot weeka dot CSV panelists have a
look at the data set. What does it look like?
I'll click on the line weather and then I hit on
the control and enter button. And then let's type
in weather. Okay, so this is wanting me to see,
let's go with head and then weather. Okay,
and so we see that there are five columns
outlook, temperature, humidity, windy and play.
Right. And let's have a look at the data type
of the data set, we see that the outlook
has three factor levels play has two factor
levels. So these are categorical label. No,
yes. And the outlook is overcast, rainy and
sunny. Windy is a true and false humidity and
temperature are integers. And so a random forest
model will be created by using the four variables
comprising of Outlook temperature, humidity,
windy as the input variable, and the play variable
here will be used as the output variable or the
variable that we want to predict. Okay, and in
the data equals to weather, which is the weather
data object here. And we're going to use number of
three to be five lines read. And because there are
four input variables, we're just going to use em
try a four. Okay, so let's try building a model
and the model has been built. And let's apply
the model for prediction, shall we, I mean,
just to test that the code is working properly.
So let's try applying the model on the input file
that I have previously mentioned about. And so
we're going to run this line and putting the data
into the variable called test can and we're going
to assign the factor because if we don't do it,
then it'll provide an error. So before we run this
line of code, let's just try to make a prediction
model. And we should be able to see a error coming
up. Okay, so we got this error error in predict
random forest type of predictor in new data do
not match. So what we notice is that if we type
in the str, and then we type in weather, and then
we notice that the outlook has factors with three
level, but if we type in str, and then the test
variable, notice that the outlook has a factor of
only one level. And this is because the input data
has only one line of data, which is essentially
one row of data. And so the outlook is only sunny
for the prediction being made has only one role.
And but in reality, it should have three levels of
the factor. So we're gonna define that by telling
the code that there are three possible factors
there are overcast, rainy, and sunny. So let's
run that line of code and then run the prediction
again, okay, and it works. And then print outputs.
And here we go, we got the prediction, which
is exactly what is going to be displayed on the
web application. Let me show you. Right, we make
the prediction, and shown here. So this table you
see here is shown right here. So the model works,
and let's go to the other lines of code. So the
next one would be the user interface. Right. As
I mentioned in previous video, the user interface
represents the first component of the shiny web
app. And this is followed by the second component,
which is the server and then this is followed by
the third component, which is the fusion of the
user interface and the server component using
the shiny app function. So let's talk about the
UI. So this UI object makes use of the fluid
page function And we're going to use the theme
equals to the shiny theme united. And so
the United theme will give the buttons
a red color. So if we change it to thoroughly and
then we're going to have the thruline color theme,
which is a bit blue. Okay, so please refer to the
first video of the web apps in our in order to
see the selection of web templates that you can
choose from. Okay, so let's run the app again.
And I'm going to put the app just about right,
right here. So the header panel is play golf.
And so this is right here, play golf. So if you
want to change the name, feel free to do so.
And then the next one is the sidebar panel. So the
sidebar panel will accept the input parameters is
located to the left, and there will be a total of
four input. And so the first one is select input,
which is a drop down menu. And if you click on it,
you get three selections, Sunny, overcast, rainy,
and when you hover on the drop down menu on sunny
it will secretly under the hood, select the sunny
object, and if you select on the overcast also, it
will under the hood be equivalent to the overcast
object. If you select on the rainy it will be
equivalent to the rainy object and the default
is to select rainy, right here we'll select rainy
as the default What if you change it to sunny
now let's change the value to be a high
value, let's say like 85 and humidity to be
95. And it's windy, that's true. Reload the app
again, right. So high temperature high humidity
windy, Sunny, don't play golf. Okay, so here you
can change the default value to your liking. Okay,
so we have mentioned about the three data
objects four here, Sunny, overcast and
rainy. So keep that in mind, we're going to
make use of data in the server function. And
note that when we will refer to it later on in
the server function, it will be referred to as
input dollar sign outlook input dollar sign
temperature input, dollar sign humidity and
input dollar sign windy. Here, why don't we just
scroll down and have a look here input dollar sign
outlook input dollar sign temperature input dollar
sign humidity input dollar sign windy, okay. And
then let's move back up. Notice the spelling here
using the small letter not the Capital One. So the
Capital One Here are the label. So it's exactly
what we're going to see in the web application
outlook with the colon is right here on the label.
Okay, actually, you don't have to type in label
if you don't want to, we could just you know,
delete it, and it will give the same results.
It's just implied, okay. But if you want to add
the label argument, you could feel free to do so.
Right? But if you do it for one, well might
as well do it for all. So that would actually
make the code looks a bit more easier to read.
Right. So let me see here that okay, this is the
object name, Outlook. And the label is outlook
with a capital O reload the app. Here you go.
Right, it works as usual. So here, this outlook
here is that outlook object. And this temperature
here is the temperature object. And this action
button here is the submit button. So this Submit
button is added in order to overcome the reactive
function. So we're just at the familiar Submit
button so that users can initiate the prediction
process when they feel ready to do so instead of
having the web app being reactive and making the
prediction spontaneously upon sliding up and down
of the input values. Because when it's reactive,
if you move it by one notch, and then you let go
of the mouse, it'll make a prediction. But for
this one with the submit button, no prediction
will be made until you actually click on the
submit button to actually this might be a good
thing on the server side because the server will
work a bit less if the prediction being made is
made only once versus if it is in the reactive
mode. If you slide the input value and you just
change your mind later on. Then prediction will
be made at each point off the changing of the
input value of the slider here or even the drop
down menu, right. But we do it once with the use
of the submit button. Okay, and that's it for this
left sidebar panel. And then the main panel here
will display the result from the output generated
by the server function. So we're going to talk
about that in just a moment. So why don't we
note that the output being generated by the
server component will be called contents and
table data. Okay. Okay, so let's hop on to the
server function which is the second component. So
in this data set in Put variable it will comprise
of the first component is it will create a data
frame which will accept four input values from
the web application compressing off the outlook
temperature, humidity windy, which is right here
outlook temperature humidity windy, and then it
will combine it with the play variable, which is
the fifth column of the original data set and then
it will transpose the data set it will rotate it
in will transpose it and then write a input dot
CSV file, it will read the input that CSV file
back in into the test variable. And then it
will apply the factor function in order to tell
that the outlook has three levels. And finally, a
prediction will be made using the model generated
earlier by means of the random forest and apply
the prediction model to predict the input values
from the user. And once the prediction is made, it
will be sent from here into the output dollar sign
table data as the function data set input right
here. And then it's going to render the table
as we will see in the web application. So the
table that is being rendered will be right here,
which comprises of three columns to prediction
the know in the Yes, probability k and this status
output textbox is just essentially this box right
here. So if we load the app for the first time,
it will just say server is ready for calculation.
And if we click on the submit button, the text
will change to calculation complete and it will
be followed by the prediction results table. Okay,
so note that there are two output being generated
right here output dollar sign contents, output
dollar sign table data. So these two outputs will
be sent to the UI component right here, table data
and contents, table data will be displayed
as a table using the table output function.
And the status of the prediction whether it
is ready for prediction or prediction has been
made will be displayed by the verbatim text
output function K. And this is just a label
of the status output text box shown right here
that we're going to have the H three font size,
I mean, if you want to change it to H to
make it a bit bigger than you will notice
that the font will become bigger, right? So
I'm just going to make it back to h3. Okay.
So that's all right. And then the last component
shiny app function, which is fused the UI and the
server together again, you have all of this in
121 lines of code. And so nothing fancy here,
just a simple web application that you
can create using the shiny language.
Okay, so this video represents the fourth episode
of the web apps in our series. And today we're
going to cover about how we can develop a Iris
predictor, which is a machine learning model
in the background. And the web app allows the
user to select the input values for the four
input parameters and press on the submit button
and make a prediction. So without further ado,
let's get started. Okay, so the first thing that
you want to do is go to the data Professor GitHub.
Okay, once you arrive here, you click on the code
link, and then find SHINee, and then click on the
serial zero for Iris predictor. So what you want
to do now is to download the first three files
comprising of the app numeric dot, our app, slider
dot r and the model dot r, because the other three
files found below will be generated automatically
when we run the code. Okay, so why don't we just
click on each of them manually. And then for
each, right click on the raw button and click
on the Save Link As a key and then you select
the location in your computer where you want
to save the files. So you do this for all three
files, the app numeric that our apps are and the
model dot r. Okay, so I have already done that.
And I will go back to the our studio application.
Okay, so before we begin, let's have a look
at what the the iris predictor web application
that we are going to develop today looks like so
you want to hit on the run app, you need to make
sure that your working directory is at the folder
where it contains all of the necessary files to be
run the one that you have just downloaded.
Okay, and once you have made sure already,
you want to click on the run app button.
Alright, so this is what the app looks like.
And it allows you to put in the four input
parameters. And so these are the default
values which you can adjust accordingly. And
then when you click on the submit button,
the prediction will be made. And
here the prediction is made to be
that the input parameter is predicted to be a
Iris setosa flower and the probability of it
being a Irish atossa is 100% sense, okay,
and so if you change the input parameters
and so the prediction will also be changed
because the input parameter will be feed
into the predictive model, which is a random
forest. And then the random forest will perform
the classification. And it has classified this
input parameter as a Iris virginica with 100%
probability. So let's have a look under the hood,
what does the code actually looks like? Okay,
so the first code that you want to open up right
now is the model dot r. So in this tutorial,
we're going to pre build the random forest
model, and then we're going to load it in,
right. So as you recall, in the previous videos
of this channel, we have shown you how you can
deploy your predictive model into a RDS file. And
so what you want to do is you develop the model in
this model, dot our file, and you save it as an
RDS, right? So you're deploying that. And then
you're going to read that in here on line number
15, you're going to read the model dot RDS n, and
you're going to give it a name, the name is model,
and then we're going to use this model for making
the prediction. So the advantage of this is that
the model is already built. And so there is no
additional workload on the shiny application. So
it can just readily read in the model and perform
the classification. So this will be beneficial in
the case in which the predictive model will take a
long time to build the model. Okay, so let's have
a look at the model dot our file where we will
be building the model. So the first steps that we
want to do now is to load in the libraries, which
will include the our curl and the random forest.
So the our curl library will allow us to read the
data Professor GitHub to download the iris data
set, and then the random forest will be used to
create the prediction model. And we also need the
carrot package in order to do the data splitting.
Okay, so Iris here will mean that we will create
a data object called Iris because we're going to
read in the CSV, which will retrieve the CSV
file from the data Professor GitHub, and the
file is called Iris dot CSV, okay, and it will
use the carrot package to perform data splitting,
using a ratio of 8020 to 0.8. Here is to 80%
split, which will go into the training index, and
then we will subsequently use the training index
to create a training set in which it will perform
slicing of the original Iris data frame, and then
the remainder 20% will go to the testing set.
So what we're going to do next is we're going to
write the training set and the testing set out
into the CSV files, right, because that would help
to remedy possible shuffling of the data that will
go into the training set and the testing set, so
it will allow reproducibility in the future. So in
the future, we can just read in the training dot
CSV file, instead of performing the data splitting
again, right. So here, we're going to read in the
training dot CSV file and give it the same name,
which is the train set Canada, we're going to
delete the first column, which is the index
number. And then we're going to build a model and
assign the built model into the model data object.
And once a model has been built, we're going to
save it as the RDS file. So the we're going to
deploy the model into the RDS format. So in this
random forest function code, we're specifying that
we want to predict the species of the iris flower.
And we're going to use all four input parameters
and the data set, we'll be using the training
set for making the model and then we're going
to assign a entry value, which is the parameter of
the random forest to be five Heinz red, and we're
going to assign the M try parameter to be four,
right, and then we're going to assign a true value
for the importance argument, okay, and so so while
you want to do is you want to run all of this
blocks of code, so you could just Ctrl A,
select everything and then Ctrl, enter.
Okay, and then the data will be read, and then
a model will be built, and it will be saved as
the model dot RDS. Okay, so this
concludes the model dot our file,
and then we're going to close that. And
then we're going to open up the second file,
which is the app gnumeric dot r k. So let's have
a look. The first few lines will be importing the
necessary libraries, which will be the shiny
library, the data dot table, the random forest
package, and then we're going to read in the
model that we have built in the previous step.
And we're going to assign it into a model
object, right. And then like in previous video,
the shiny web application will contain three
components. So the first component being the UI,
and the second component being the server. And
the third component being the shiny app function,
which will essentially piece together the UI and
the server. Okay, so let's have a look at the UI.
And we're going to open up the web application
and have a look right at the same time.
And for readability of the code, I would just add
additional enters to it and new line to it. So
that when I open up the web browser, concurrently
The values here won't be hidden. Okay? Save it and
go back to the web application. Alright, so here,
the name of this web application is called Iris
predictor. And so it is in the header panel here.
So we put in the iris predictor, if you want to
change the name, feel free to do so right here.
And then we're going to have the sidebar panel,
which is on the left, and then we're going to
have the main bar panel, which is on the right,
so as always, the left or the sidebar panel will
take in the input parameters, and then clicking
on the submit button, which is right here, it will
send the input parameters to the server function,
and the server will use that input parameters to
feed it in to the predictive model, which is the
random forest model and make a prediction.
And once your prediction has been made,
the resulting output value generated will then be
feed back into the main panel right here. And then
the results will be displayed in the table data,
which is going to be occurring right below this
text message. So the table data will be shown
right here, which is the prediction being made.
Okay, so in the input parameters, we're going to
use the HTML tag and inside we're going to assign
a size of the header to be h3 right, and a name
will be input parameters right here. So further
showing the versatility of the shiny application
framework. So notice that the s and l are capital
letter, and this is the ID of this input parameter
sepal length, and it is case sensitive. So we have
to type it in exactly S is when we're going to
use it in the next step. So it's going to be
like input dollar sign, and then CBOE dot length.
And then this will be the input parameter, which
the server function will be using as the data to
be fed into the random forest model. Okay, and so
the label here will be sepal length. And the label
means right here, the label and the value is the
default value, which is five and here is five. So
if you change the default value to 5.1, and you
save it, run the app again. So you see that the
5.1 will be updated right here in place of the
5.0. Okay, so the same thing will be for the sepal
width, petal length and petal width, right with
the label and with the value, which is the default
value right here. And then the next block of code
here is the action button function. And this will
be the submit button. So it will overwrite the
reactive function in which when there is no Submit
button, every time we modify the numbers in here,
a prediction will be made. So that would put a
heavy load onto the server, because every time
that you update the value here, a prediction will
be made. So imagine that you update the values 10
times 20 times and 20 predictive models will be
created. Whereas in a situation where you have
the submit button, you can spend all the time or
as many times as you need to update the values,
right? Let's see if I went to and then I changed
my mind, I want to have it 4.9. So do this 10
more times. And so the prediction model will
not be built, right. So it's going to wait for
you until you click on the submit button and then
the prediction will be made. Okay, so this will be
more economical on the server side. And also for
familiarity, where we normally would click on some
button in order to initiate the process of the
prediction. Okay, and then the following block of
code main panel will be right here. So in the tax
label h3 status output, it will be this part. So
notice that this block of code is exactly the same
as the HTML block of code. So I'm just showing you
the versatility of the shiny web application.
And you could use either one, okay, but this
is the shiny way of doing things, right. So let
me show you by putting it right here. And then
I'm going to comment that out and put in the APR
parameters here and then replace the value inside.
Okay, reload the application, right, and then it
looks exactly the same, right. So you can do it
both ways, right, and then the following text box
shown here will tell you that the server is ready
for calculation. So this will be displayed upon
loading of the web application. And upon clicking
on the submit button, the value will be changed
to be calculation complete. Okay, so this will
be on the server side. So I will show you in
just a moment. Okay, so we finished with the
UI component. And now let's go on to the server
component. And so here we're going to load in the
function, okay, so this block of code here will
be the input parameters, which will be obtained
from the UI component where the user will input
the input parameters and click on Submit button.
And upon doing that, all of the input parameters
will come in as shown in this block of code here.
And this block of code will essentially generate
the input CSV file, which will be read into the
test object and then apply the model to
make a prediction on this test object.
And once the prediction has been made, this block
of code data set input will contain the prediction
and the prediction value will be inserted right
here, right and it's going to be encapsulated by
a output table data variable name and then
This thing and then the input dollar sign,
and then the output dollar sign table data will be
sent to the main panel in the UI to be displayed.
So it's right here, right. So this one will
come from the table data right here, table data,
right this highlighted in blue, and it will
be coming from the prediction results table,
right, which we use the render table function
here, and the data set input here will contain
the prediction which is coming out from the output
data object. Okay, so let me go specifically line
by line here. So a data frame will be created, and
then name will be the name of the Heather variable
name on the first row, and then the values will
take and the input parameter value from the UI.
So input dollar sign, sepal length, sepal width,
petal length, petal width will come from the
input text box right here 5.1 3.6 1.4 2.2. So
these text box will be the input dollar sign,
sepal length, sepal width, petal length, petal
width, okay, and then we're going to create a
data frame. And once we have done that, we
will write it out as a input dot CSV file.
Now we're going to read it back in, and then
we're going to put it into the test object,
and then we're going to create a output object
and a data frame will be created. And we apply
the prediction function in order to make
a prediction using the random forest model
on the input test data. And once the prediction
has been made, we will also tell the probability
in three digits Okay, and once a prediction has
been made, it will then be sent to this output
data object and it will print it out and it will
be representing the data set inputs, and this
data set input will be inserted into the render
table function, and a table will be generated
to show you the output prediction results shown
right here. Right. Okay. So that's essentially
it for this Iris predictor in the numeric form.
So let's close this and hop on to the next one.
Okay, so now we're going to proceed with the app
slider version. And before doing so you want to
clean the workspace environment. So click on the
broom button. And then after you have done that,
then you want to click on the app, slider
dot r and then Ctrl, a, and then Ctrl, enter.
Right, and then the web app will be loaded. So
you see that now instead of a tap spots where
we put in the numerical value, you're going
to have a slider, right and then you click on
the input parameter by sliding here, and then
after you're satisfied with the input values,
then you will click on the submit button, and
then the prediction will be made. And as always,
it looks exactly the same, but the only difference
is the input parameters will have the slider bar
instead of the textbox. Okay, so let's have a
look under the hood. So what new code did we
add to this file, so we've added line 1718, and
19. And then we've also added two new arguments,
which is the minimum and the maximum argument
into each of the inputs. And we also change the
name from numeric input into slider input.
And that's essentially it, we just change
a couple of lines of code and the web app will
look like this. Instead of a numeric text box,
we're going to have a slider bar. So the value
of the minimum here will be taken as the minimum
function and then the train set dollar sign simple
link, right. So I don't have to manually put in
the minimum value or maximum value, but I will
do this programmatically. So I'm going to use
the minimum function and inside the minimum
function as the argument, I'm going to say,
Okay, I want to have the train set object. And I
want to have the simple link column. And I want
to know what is the minimum value, right, it's
going to be like this. So let me close this,
and I'm going to read in the file. So let me
show you how it looks like. And if I run the
train set, it will look like this. And then
I'm going to run this line and then notice that
the first column will be gone, right, I don't
want the index to be shown. So I just deleted out.
And then when I say train set dollar sign
sepal length, where they get will be this,
so it's going to be the values of only the first
column. And upon adding the minimum function
in front, I'm going to get the minimum value. And
if I use the maximum function, I'm going to get
the maximum value of this column. So the minimum
is 4.3. And the maximum is 7.9. So instead of
putting in the values manually, 4.3 7.9, I'm going
to do it programmatically, and it's going to be
so much easier, right? And then I just put it
in right here. And that's all for modifying the
code and everything else works exactly the same.
And you get a new feel to the web application
and it's not that difficult. Okay, So play around
and let me know what kind of web application you
want to be made and Or the input data that
you want me to use for making the web app.
Okay, so today represents the fifth episode
of the web apps in our series. And today we're
going to cover about how you can develop a BMI
calculator. So if you're wondering what is a BMI,
so essentially, BMI stands for body mass index,
and it is computed by dividing the weight in
kilograms by the heights in square meters. So for
example, if you weighed 70 kilograms and you are
170 centimeters tall, then you would first have to
convert the height to a meter. So 170 centimeters
would then become 1.7 meters. And according
to the equation, you would take your weight,
which is 70 kilograms divided by 1.7 meter
squared, okay, so let me calculate that. So 1.7
times 1.7, would be 2.89. And if I weighed 70
kilograms, divide that by the squared heights,
then my BMI would be 24.2. Okay, so let's have a
look at the scale of the BMI in adults. So if you
have a BMI below 18.5, then it would mean that you
are underweight. If you have a BMI in the range
of 18.5 and 24.9, then it means that you have a
healthy weight. And if your BMI is between 25 to
29.9, it means that you are overweight. And if you
have a BMI of greater than 30, then you are obese.
Okay, so in the previous example, a BMI of 24.2
would mean that the weight is a healthy weight.
So without further ado, let's get started in
developing our BMI web application. So you
want to go first to the GitHub of the data
professor. And so click on the code folder,
find shiny and click on the shiny folder.
And then find the 005 that BMI click on that.
And then you want to download both the
about.md and the app dot r into your computer.
So why don't we do that, right, right
click on the raw to save link as because
we're going to download it into a BMI folder. We
save it there. And then download the second file,
right click on the raw link, safely add as save
it to the folder BMI. Okay, and now we have
to upload the folder. Okay, there you have it,
you have two files at that R and about.md. So
let's have a quick look at what this file look
like. So as you show the app dot r is the art
code comprising of the three major components, the
UI, the user interface, number two is the server.
And number three is the signing out function which
fuses both the UI and the server function. And in
the second file, you have the about.md. So this is
written in the markdown language. And it's going
to be used by the app dot our file. So we're going
to see that in just a moment. So before we dive
deep into the our code, let's have a look what the
web application looks like. Click on the run app.
Okay, so this is a simple web application where
you can put in your input height and your weight,
so the height will be in centimeters and the
weight will be in kilograms. So the minimum
value here is 40 for the heights, and 250 for the
maximum value, and for the weight, the minimum
value is 20. And the maximum value is 100. So
please note that this BMI calculator is developed
for adults and it's not suitable for children.
If you want to develop a BMI for children, then
we will have to refer to this second link here.
Okay, so as you notice that when they click on
the about link on the navigation bar, it shows
the information in the About page. So originally,
the code was written here in markdown language and
here in the website. It displays it as a Normal
webpage. So here you can add boldness to the
text, you can add superscript make it stand out
as an equation, you could add italic font, right.
So all of this is within the markdown language,
right? For example, if you for example, if you
use two asterisks, it will mean that the tests
will be in bold text. So meaning that you have
to use two asterisks before and after the test,
you want to meet both. And if you use the for
hash tag, it means that you are going to use the
Heather level for tag, which is the h4 tag
in HTML. And if you're using the greater than
symbol here, it means that it's going to display
this light gray bar to the left. So you know that
it's a equation. And if you use one asterisk, then
it means that the tax will be in Tillich form,
right. And here we use it for hash
tagging in and so it becomes a header.
And then we make the BMI calculator in Italy
form by using the asterisk before and after,
and even add the links to the website, right.
So the taps that you want to make into a link,
you have to put that in bracket and immediately
following that, you have to put in parenthesis the
URL of the webpage. And so this is format to like
a normal web page. And so the web application,
and so the web application, it's mobile friendly,
and you can use it on your mobile phone, okay,
it would look something like this on the phone.
And if you click on it, and you get the BMI,
right, in my previous example, a
height of 170 and a weight of 70,
you will get a BMI of 24.2 to 145. And because
we're rounding it, and therefore we get 24.22.
Okay, so this web application seems simple enough,
okay. And so let's dive deep into the code. Okay,
so let's have a look at the code of the app dot
our file. So the first two lines here will be the
loading in of the library package of shiny and
shiny themes. And then following that we have
the user interface. So inside the UI optic, it's
going to be the fluid page function. And here,
we will define that we're going to use the
shiny theme of united and first run the app and
have a look. So here at the nav bar page function
shows that we're going to use the name of this
navigation bar to be BMI calculator. And then the
tab panel will have the first navigation tab here
to be home. Okay, and inside top panel here, we're
going to use the sidebar panel and the main panel.
So as usual, the sidebar panel is right here to
the left, and to the right, in the status output,
we're going to have the main panel, right so the
sidebar panel will contain the input parameters,
which comprises of two input parameters, the
height and the weight, and we're using a slider
input, so you can slide the bar here, and then you
get the desired value, click on the submit button,
and then you get the calculated BMI value. Okay,
so the slider input here is responsible for this
slider button. And so the name of this slider
input is called height here in label height.
And the first one will be the ID of this specific
slider inputs. And so this slider input has an ID
of heights, notice the small h and then the second
slider input has a value of weights and notice the
small W and so these two slider input will then
be used in the next step, it will be used by the
server function as the input dollar sign
weights and input dollar sign heights in order
to calculate the BMI, okay, and then the action
button function will be the red button that you
click to initiate the calculation process.
And so the main panel will have h3 tag here
showing the status outputs Okay, and then the
verbatim text output will contain the contents
ID, which is from the output in the server
function. And in the table output is also
from the output of the server function, it is
called the table data. And this is the table
data containing the computed BMI value. So let
me recap that again. So here the slider input,
we have to work them height and weight and so it
will be referred to as input dollar sign heights
input dollar sign weights. And as the user
slides this value, it will adjust the value
to the height parameter or the weight parameter
and the input dollar sign height value and the
input dollar sign weight value will then go to
the server function. I will show you right now,
right here. So we go to the server function in
the equation that we're going to create puti BMI.
So here we're taking the input dollar sign weight,
dividing it by the in parenthesis, the input
dollar sign height divided by 100, right, because
we want to convert the centimeters to become
meter, so we have to divide the centimeter value
by our friends read, and that will then make it
a major form. And then we're going to multiply the
height by itself so that we get the squared height
value. And then we're going to divide the weight
by the height in order to get the BMI. And we're
going to encapsulate the BMI value inside a data
frame so that we can display it in the final
output here below in the output contents, it will
show that the server is ready for calculation or
the server has already completed the calculation.
So this will be modified by the submit button,
the red button that we clicked right here. So
when we don't click the button, it will say
server is ready for calculation. But upon clicking
on the red button, the BMI will be calculated.
And then in this text box, the text will change
to calculation complete kn in the following output
results here is called the output dollar sign
table data. And inside here, we're going to
use the render table function. So the results
from the data set input will be the computed
BMI value right here in the print BMI. So let
me recap again, let's have a look at the web
application again. So this web application will
take two input parameters, the height and weight,
and they are in the centimeter unit and the
height and the weight will be referred to as
input dollar sign heights and input dollar sign
weights. And upon clicking on the red button,
it will be sent to the server function into this
BMI calculator function. So it will then take the
input weights and the input height and perform
the calculation and return the BMI value. And
then we put the BMI value into a data frame. And
then we print it out and the results of the BMI
is printing out is part of the data set input
variable. And that is called within the render
table function of the output dollar sign table
data and the output dollar sign table data
will go to the main panel right here in the
main panel to be displayed in the table output.
And it looks like this right here. So you see
that it's called BMI and then we have to BMI
value right beneath it, right. And that's all
there is to building this BMI web application.
So you can play around with this code. And you can
change the default value, for example, the height,
you can make it 180 and the value of
the weight, you could make it say 75,
right and then run the code again. So the default
value then becomes updated to be 180 and 75.
So let's say that you want to update the
maximum value to be 300, minimum value to
be 50. And the weight, you want to update
it to say 30. And the maximum would be 120.
And then we load the application and here you
see the minimum values and maximum values are
updated accordingly. So you see here,
if the weight is maintained the same and
the height increases, then the BMI becomes less.
But if the height decreases, then the BMI is high,
right because of the equation
of the BMI, whereby the
weight is divided by the height squared, okay,
and so you can play around existing values,
playing around with the template. So let's say
you want to change the United theme to become a
Boolean. Save it, reload the app, and
here you go, you get a different colored
web application. Right. So the types of theme
could be obtained by looking at the websites.
You can Google that Google for shiny themes,
click on the click on the art studio.github.io
slash shiny themes. So I'll provide the link in
the description down below. So check that out.
In this video, I'm going to show you how
you could deploy a shiny web application.
And without further ado, we're starting right
now. Okay, so the first thing that you want
to do is head over to the GitHub of the data
professor. And you want to click on repositories,
then find and click on the iris, our Heroku.
And so all of the files that are needed to deploy
your app is found here. So feel free to clone this
to your own GitHub or also you could download the
entire folder content here by clicking on the code
and then download zip file. So let's have a
look here. So you're gonna see that we have
the UI dot r, which is the user interface. And we
also have server dot r, which is the server side
component of the web app. So essentially, the our
shiny web app will be comprised of two components,
the user interface and the server component. And
then we're going to have the training data set
and the testing data set as the CSV file. And the
actual model will be contained within the model
dot RDS. And so the machine learning model is
saved as the model dot RDS. And it will be loaded
into the web application when we run it. And then
there are two additional r files. Let's have a
look. So the first one is in that dot r. And so
let's have a look here. So it will allow us to
install the necessary libraries. So we're going to
install the random forest and the data dot table.
And the run dot r will allow us to run the R
shiny and assign the proper ports. Okay. And
so that's all there is to having the necessary
components for deploying your our shiny web
application. So let's head over to Hiroko. And
so you want to click on new create new app.
And then you want to give the app a
name. So let me call it VP, Iris, our
create app. And then I want to connect to GitHub.
And I'll find Iris or he Roku. So for your case,
you want to find your own GitHub and you want
to find your own RSR he Roku and then connect.
And then this is very important, because you
want to click on settings. And in order to have
the support for our, you're going to need to add
the custom build pack. And so you want to click on
the Add build pack. And you're going to notice
that there are some officially supported build
packs. So by default, you're going to have Python,
right, and you're going to have others like PHP,
Ruby, Java, node j s. And so for our we're going
to use a third party. And the third party link to
the build pack for R is given here. So I'm going
to provide you this link in the description of
this video. So you want to copy that and then put
it here as well. And then click on save changes.
And then you're going to see that it has been
added successfully here. Now you want to head
back to deploy, scroll down and you want to
click on deploy branch in the manual deploy.
So at this point, you want to take a break, grab a
cup of coffee and wait for the web app to deploy.
So we're gonna see the log
of what is happening here.
So initially, it is installing version 3.6,
point three here. And it is downloading
the bill pack directly from Amazon Web
Service, and also having shiny as well.
Right, so it's installing
the data dot table library.
And right now it's building the environment.
So this web application has already been built
in a previous video. So the link to that video
will be provided in the description down below.
And in the meantime, maybe I could show you that
shiny and it is number four Iris predictor.
And so you're going to notice that we've been
using the testing and training and for the app,
we divided the components of UI and
server into these separate files.
Okay, and so it's compressing the environment
from 499 megabytes to 121 megabytes.
Although the our packages occupies 121 megabytes,
okay, so it has compressed it down to 152.
And it is deploying the web application
to dp that's Iris dash r dot e Roku
app.com. And so in just a moment, you're going
to see a link to view the deployed websites.
Okay, finished. And so it says that your app
was successfully deployed. Let's click on it.
Alright, so it says here that server is ready
for a calculation. Let's submit All right,
so predictions seems to work and it is predicted
to be setosa with the probability of 100%.
k this predicted to be pseudoscience. Well,
same thing she told us and now
it was predicted to be virginica.
100% virginica. Thank you for watching
until the end of this video, and I hope
that this video was helpful to you. And for
more tutorials in data science, Bioinformatics,
as well as Python and our coding tutorials, please
check out my YouTube channel at the data professor
and also my new and second YouTube channel
decoding professor. And you can also find
me on the medium platform where I blog about
data science as well as doing Python tutorials.
And last but not least, I would like to thank
Free Code Camp for this awesome collaboration.
And please don't forget to smash the like button,
subscribe if you haven't already. And until next
time, the best way to learn data science is to
do data science, and please enjoy the journey.